all right another live look from aliante
park getting shots of the pond there and
the ducks and you can feed those ducks
there too by the way uh if you want this
location because this is a really cool
park i love the dinosaurs they have in
this park you can bury the eggs and then
uncover the actual bones i'm serious
kirsten this is this really cool park uh
henry takan my buddies out there
shooting this live shot he's like hey
i've gotten i'm getting turtles out here
there you go henry good job with the
turtle shots you can try to feed them
but they jump into the pond before you
can get to them unfortunately well
camera shy right if you want to know
that location go to 215 beltway to the
north take a right on aliante parkway
don't go left towards the casino go
right and you'll run into that park flow
facts for today we could reach our first
90 degree day of the year today last
year we reached our first 90
on april 3rd
so early this year right and i just
found out too i was just checking the
national weather service twitter page
too because they tell us the official
high 88 degrees so far means we already
broke the previous record set back in
1987.
yes where the balloons and the confetti
where's the guy on stilts
he's not not here all right air quality
good if we're going to get this warm we
might as well reach a record right
83 in centennial hills summerlin 81
degrees 88 you guys we sell time for
bringing popcorn just so you know 88 for
sunrise matt we love eights here at
channel eight we love em 89 for seven
hills 84 rhodes ranch southern highlands
91
90 for henderson right now outside the
valley 89 for prom death value for sure
are 90s 94 degrees right now 88 for
boulder city we could reach 100 in death
valley because remember it's only three
o'clock we still have several hours
before we actually reach our daytime
high the reason for the heat is the high
pressure still in charge of the region
you can see all this going up and over
this high right now so it's hot here but
even hotter in phoenix of course outside
here is what we're going to see approach
us later on over the weekend we'll get
increasing clouds from this down here
but this trough out here the will bring
in the winds and the cooler air for us
for early on next week but let's focus
on our weekend all right just how caught
will it get 91 degrees on saturday that
of course is going to be another record
breaker because that record was 87
degrees set back in 1947 it's been that
long saturday sunday we're not going to
reach that record but we'll come close
86 our forecast high the record 88
degrees notice both days we're looking
at partly sunny skies so won't see
entirely blue skies this weekend but
it'll still be nice your futurecast does
show increased shower chances on monday
stray showers and possibly look at this
tuesday too
and then we get a break on wednesday and
there's a slight chance look at this
returning on thursday that's not a big
chance right now but we could have
several days we'll have some
opportunities for showers for next week
yes we could certainly use it out here
62 overnight we'll see increasing clouds
coming in from the west a mild start to
our morning i'm 62 for your morning it's
going to be real nice for that morning
walk i'll be snoozing though 91 degrees
for tomorrow
record heat again for tomorrow like we
talked about we'll see a mix of sun and
clouds and increase wind like we talked
about maybe you've got recreation to do
it i got you covered mount charleston
now 67 degrees tomorrow nice and mild it
will become breezy though
as the day progresses but these stronger
winds will come on sunday if you're
going to the lake tomorrow it's going to
be hot for sure 98 degrees for you
tomorrow at the lake uh near 100 degrees
for laughlin increasing winds and again
hot and partly sunny for tomorrow here
is your eight day forecast like we
talked about the shower chances monday
tuesday cooling off to the low 70s
that's going to feel nice and we'll stay
in those 70s for next week too so those
90s won't last too long back to you